[Music]
what's your sign
in western astrology it's a
constellation determined by when your
birthday falls in the calendar but
according to the chinese zodiac or
xiangxiao it's your shui
meaning the animal assigned to your
birth year
and of the many myths explaining these
animal signs and their arrangement the
most enduring one is that of the great
race
as the story goes ud or jade emperor
ruler of the heavens wanted to devise a
way to measure time so he organized a
race
the first 12 animals to make it across
the river would earn a spot on the
zodiac calendar in the order they
arrived the rat rose with the sun to get
an early start but on the way into the
river he met the horse the tiger and the
ox
because the rat was small and couldn't
swim very well he asked the bigger
animals for help while the tiger and
horse refused the kind-hearted ox agreed
to carry the rat across
yet just as they were about to reach the
other side the rat jumped off the ox's
head and secured first place
the ox came in second with the powerful
tiger right behind him the rabbit too
small to battle the current nimbly
hopped across stones and logs to come in
forth
next came the dragon who could have
flown directly across but stopped to
help some creatures she had encountered
on the way
after her came the horse galloping
across the river but just as she got
across the snake slithered by
the startled horse reared back letting
the snake sneak into sixth place
the jade emperor looked out at the river
and spotted the sheep the monkey and the
rooster all atop a raft working together
to push it through the weeds
when they made it across the trio agreed
to give eighth place to the sheep who
had been the most comforting and
harmonious of them followed by the
monkey and the rooster
next came the dog scrambling onto the
shore he was a great swimmer but
frolicked in the water for so long that
he only managed to come in 11th
the final spot was claimed by the pig
who had gotten hungry and stopped to eat
and nap before finally waddling across
the finish line
and so each year is associated with one
of the animals in this order with the
cycle starting over every 60 years
why 60 and not 12
well the traditional chinese calendar is
made up of two overlapping systems
the animals of the zodiac are associated
with what's called the twelve earthly
branches or sharding
another system the ten heavenly stems or
shithyangan
is linked with the five classical
elements of metal
water
fire
each element is assigned yin or yang
creating a 10 year cycle when the 12
animals of the earthly branches are
matched with the five elements plus the
yin or the yang of the heavenly stems it
creates 60 years of different
combinations known as a sexagenary cycle
or kanji
so someone born in 1980 would have the
sign of young metal monkey while someone
born in 2007 would be in fire pig
in fact you can also have an inner
animal based on your birth month a true
animal based on your birth date and a
secret animal based on your birth hour
it was the great race that supposedly
determined which animals were enshrined
in the chinese zodiac but as the system
spread through asia other cultures made
changes to reflect their communities
so if you consult the vietnamese zodiac
you may discover that you're a cat not a
rabbit
and if you're in thailand a mythical
snake called a naga replaces the dragon
so whether or not you play stock and
what the zodiac says about you as an
individual it certainly reveals much
about the culture it comes from
[Music]
you